the Sun drop and moonstone are two of
the most important objects from
Rapunzel's tangled adventure series but
these pieces of magic are seriously
complicated there is so much we don't
know about these ancient marvels but
that won't be the case for long keep
watching to find out what makes the Sun
drop and moonstone so powerful and why
they need each other to exist the Sun
drop flower the history of the Sun drop
flower goes all the way back a thousand
years it's first explained in the movie
Tangled a single drop of sunlight fell
to the earth centuries before Rapunzel
was born it grew into a flower that
could be picked the pollen from this
flower has incredible powers but we'll
get to those in a minute the flower was
found by an old witch named Mother
Gothel she was a student of an evil
demon named Jean theory so she was very
powerful
she knew the incantation to sing to the
Sun drop to make it work the king and
queen of corona also knew about the sun
drop when the Queen was pregnant with
Rapunzel she became very ill the only
chance that she could be saved was by
the Sun drop the King sent out his men
to find it and bring it back to the
castle
mother Gothel tried to hide the flower
from them but she accidentally revealed
it the king's military picked the flower
and that's where everything gets really
complicated the Sun drop is the most
powerful object in all of the Seven
Kingdoms when it was picked the location
where it grew became enchanted and
sacred there's a small pedestal where
the flower grew and it's surrounded by
magical rocks called black rocks these
become really important later on these
rocks can grow anywhere and the leaf
destruction in their wake so what's the
big deal about this Sun drop well the
powers that it possesses are amazing the
Sun drop has the power of healing it can
heal anything from minor wounds to fatal
ones but that's not all it can do
because believe it or not it can
resurrect the dead it gives the owner a
really really long life and it keeps the
owner looking super young Mother Gothel
is actually pretty ancient this is why
she wanted to keep the Sun Drop for
herself when the Sun dropped flower is
fed to the Queen while she's pregnant
it totally cures her she's
able to live the pow'rs pass to Rapunzel
who hasn't been born yet
it comes out in her hair it glows and
emits power when you sing the healing
and condition but if the hair gets cut
the power leaves it bothell is the one
who discovered this the second she cut
it the hair turned brown she just really
didn't want to grow old so she stole the
baby and locked her in a tower that way
she could have all of the Sun drops
power to herself
at the end of the movie Eugen cuts her
hair but she's still the living
manifestation of the Sun drop her hair
grows back in the show after Rapunzel
touches the black rocks in The Alchemist
Returns we find out even more about the
Sun drop flower the flower itself still
exists Bavarian does an experiment on it
he learns that its powers solely live
inside of Rapunzel
she's the Sun drop we also find out in
the season one finale that removing the
Sun drop was an even bigger deal
King Frederick was warned by Kieran not
to do it if the flower was removed it
would have major consequences it would
also awaken an ancient darkness but the
King did it anyway so he could save his
wife and unborn baby no one can ever
know I took you outside the walls of
Corona don't worry no one is gonna find
out the black rocks we can't talk about
the moonstone without first talking
about the black rocks these rocks are
massive thorny things that just appear
out of nowhere they first grew around
the spot where the Sun drop was picked
the first time we learn about them is in
the TV movie Tangled before ever after
Cassandra takes Rapunzel to see where
the Sun drop comes from Rapunzel
accidentally touches these rocks and our
powers get reactivated their magical
hair grows back it also activates the
rocks a few months later they start
growing all over the place they're
headed straight for Corona these black
rocks are determined to find the Sun
drop every time she gets near them her
hair grows and so do the rocks these
rocks can destroy whole kingdoms this is
the ancient darkness that King Frederick
was warned about and the black rocks
come from the moonstone opal in season
two Rapunzel Eugene and Cassandra set
out to stop this darkness they follow
the black rocks which they believe will
lead them to the moonstone
and they do eventually and things go
very very wrong
the moonstone the magical moonstone is
introduced in the second season it first
appears in a flashback in the season 2
premiere beyond the corona walls here we
learned that there's an opal that King
Edmund believed would stop the black
rocks oh yeah he's also Eugene's real
father it turns out that this stone is
the moonstone opal King Edmund tried to
destroy the moonstone but he couldn't
he ordered Kieran and Adira to keep it a
secret this happened about 25 years
before tangled we hear about it in the
TV special Rapunzel and the Great Tree
in this episode Rapunzel and the game
discovered the magic moonstone formula
they meet Hector who is a dangerous
enemy Rapunzel has to use the moonstone
formula to save her friends but it's
completely uncontrollable so what is
this moonstone anyway this enchanted
object has a similar history to the Sun
drop at the same time that a drop of
sunlight fell to the earth so did a drop
of moonlight they each created magical
powerful objects the moonstone opal is
basically the opposite of the Sun drop
flower the power of the Sun drop is life
and the power of the moonstone is death
instead of healing things it destroys
things instead of keeping people young
it causes them to decay in fact it
basically symbolizes the afterlife the
moonstone is also activated by an
incantation but not the one we're used
to lord Dumanis and the squirrel lord de
manitous lived over a thousand years
before tangled ever took place this
magical being was both an inventor and
scientist he spent much of his life in
the battle against zon Terry Zhan was an
ancient evil demon who cast a huge
deadly blizzard over Corona he defeated
the demon and other evil spirits and
imprisoned them in a machine de manitous
was a scientist first and foremost he
went with his students to find the Sun
drop in moonstone he knew that some
major natural event had caused the
sunlight and moonlight to fall to the
earth he did a bunch of research
alongside his students demonicus knew
that if Sean got the moonstone and Sun
Drop it would be really bad he also
needed to hide all his research on these
things everything that was
own about the powerful objects was on a
scroll he divided the scroll into four
pieces and hid them all over the world
he eventually defeated Zhaan and
banished him but he still needed to hide
in case the demon came back his spirit
inhabited a monkey named fig or if this
guy really easy to manage this is a huge
honor
once he spoke to Rapunzel through Viger
and told her what she needed to know
we met de manitous and viekera in lost
and found this it's the second to last
episode of season 2 he guides them
through the maze to find the last piece
of the scroll this scroll is super
important it contains instructions on
how to unite the Sun drop in moon stone
rapunzel is the Sun drop she must get to
the moon stone it will summon the
ultimate power we don't exactly know
what this means yet but we do know that
it is the only way to stop the black
rocks from spreading if rapunzel feels
the black props we'll continue searching
for her forever they'll spread and
spread and destroy everything in their
paths de manitous also predicted that
someone in Rapunzel's group would betray
her but for some strange reason he
wouldn't tell her who this person was
what he did tell Rapunzel though is that
there was a lot she needed to figure out
on her own that's not very helpful at
all
destinies collide destinies collide it's
the final episode of season 2 this is
where everything about the Sun drop in
moonstone come together there are a ton
of big reveals in this episode it was
action-packed
and full of tiny details let's break it
down Rapunzel and her crew have finally
made it to the Dark Kingdom
Rapunzel finds out about the prophecy
that Eugene has he's super worried about
someone betraying her
Rapunzel doesn't want to believe it
would be her bestie Cassandra the group
takes some abandoned gondolas and they
encounter a warrior in a bear mass Adara
shows up remember her she was ordered by
King Edmund long ago to keep the
moonstone a secret the warrior is
actually King Edmund
you are my son
he takes Eugene to his castle we find
out all about how the dark rocks
destroyed his kingdom Edmund health
Eugene that he is his father and that
it's his duty to protect the moonstone
like all his ancestors he must even
protect it from rapunzel Eugene gets
really conflicted when Edmund could not
destroy the moonstone he evacuated his
kingdom to save his people he sent a
Derrick Ciaran and Hector to stop anyone
from finding it that's right
Hector was from the Dark Kingdom -
Eugene tries to keep Rapunzel from
entering the chamber but she finds
another way in
Cassandra convinces Rapunzel to let her
go in first and help fight there's a big
battle where they all fight against
Edmund and the ghosts of his ancestors
Edmund finally understands that Rapunzel
isn't there to use the moonstone for
evil he says that only someone who is
pure of heart and has the Sundrop powers
can enter Eugene tells him that Rapunzel
is the Sun Drop so King Edmund Lutz are
in this is a huge moment
Rapunzel is about to fulfill her destiny
she'll unite the two powers and stop the
black rocks she'll have an even greater
ultimate power but just as she reaches
for the moonstone opal cassandra reaches
out and grabs it we could not believe it
how could Cassandra do that the power of
the moonstone throws Rapunzel and the
rest of her crew back across the bridge
the moon stones magic flows through
Cassandra and changes her appearance
it destroys her armor and makes her a
new outfit out of the black rocks
themselves it also turns her hair bright
blue The Rock's begin growing like crazy
and destroying the chamber Cassandra
says it's her destiny to have the
moonstone she tells Rapunzel that she
warned her to be careful who she trusted
come on Cassandra this is not the moment
for I told you so we couldn't believe
that Cassandra did this so what does all
this mean well Cassandra making it's her
destiny to have the moonstone but we
know that she's got it all twisted
because obviously the moon stone belongs
to Rapunzel she's pure of heart and
embodies the Sun drop it's up to her to
unite them and seed the Seven Kingdoms
from the black
rocks there are a lot of theories as to
why Cassandra betrayed Rapunzel all we
know for sure is that the first episode
of season 3 is called Cassandra's
revenge what does she need revenge for
season 3 is the last season and we
already know that Rapunzel and Eugene
get married and have a happily ever
after
entangled ever after we see their
wedding and Rapunzel has her short brown
hair again something will make her lose
the Sun Drop power we can't wait to see
how it all goes down so did you see
Cassandra's betrayal coming if so let us
know which Clues gave her intentions
away and while you're at it let us know
who your favorite tangled character is
in the comments below and that's
everything we know about the Sun Drop
and moonstone hit that subscribe button
so you never miss a video from the
things and don't forget to get this
video up egg thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]